madame monsieur bonsoir aussi les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 26
décembre
c'est la plus grave tempête qui connut
paris depuis 50 ans toute la moitié nord
de la france a été balayé par des vents
très violents provoquant la mort d'au
moins 27 personnes
le réseau routier et les transports
aériens et ferroviaires sont gravement
perturbé un million et demi de foyers
sont toujours privés d'électricité ce
soir la marée noire s'étend maintenant
sur les côtes de la loire atlantique les
secouristes entre abattement et colère
dominique voynet manifeste sa solidarité
avec les sinistrés
elle a visité tout le littoral de
loire-atlantique c'est une tempête d'une
rare violence la plus forte depuis 50
ans qui a frappé la partie nord du pays
cette nuit mais aussi paris et l'île de
france
pour l'instant le bilan toujours
provisoire est de 27 morts en france
deux disparus et des dizaines de blessés
graves
jacques chirac le présente à un public
en vacances au maroc a adressé cet après
midi ses condoléances ou factices aux
familles des victimes
fait exceptionnel jean tiberi le maire
de paris demande les que l'état de
catastrophe naturelle soit déclaré dans
la région parisienne
les vents avoisiner 150 km/heure et
certains quartiers de paris offrait ce
matin un spectacle de désolation comme
ont pu le constater olivier caroff fanni
au vernis christian leroux et jacques
girard la tempête a emporté tout ce qui
faisait obstacle à sa course folle dans
les rues rien n'a résisté à même les
engins ni plus loups
une force inouïe qui pendant deux heures
ce matin jeter bas tout ce qui n'était
pas assez solide les cheminées les
arbres pas un quartier de paris qui
n'ait été épargné
ici un morceau de façade arraché le toit
les pompiers ont sorti deux blessés
graves de cet amas de débris
là c'est qu'une grue qui s'est effondré
les habitants l'ont vivacité impuissant
elle est tombée et heureusement une
tempête qui a érigé ces barrages un peu
partout dans la capitale
compliquant encore la tâche des services
de secours
dix mille interventions en quelques
heures pour les pompiers de la région
parisienne
des numéros d'urgence totalement saturé
d'appels il a fallu parer au plus pressé
dégager des axes de circulation pour
pouvoir intervenir dans cet immeuble
d'argenteuil il n'y avait
malheureusement plus rien à faire un
couple qui vivait au dernier étage a été
écrasé par les dalles de la toiture
seules leurs enfants a pu être souvent
3e juste en dessous j'ai entendu un gros
bruit pendant 3 4 secondes et à tous les
murs fissurés ou dans cet hôtel d'euro
disney on compte six blessés graves
encore un toit qui s'est effondré toute
l'île de france a été touchée par des
rafales dépassant les 150 km heure assez
pour renverser un petit avion ou
transformer le bois de boulogne en champ
de bataille
la rafale la plus violente 173 km à orly
a failli coûter la vie à un chauffeur de
taxi au moment de charger dans ce coup
j'ai entendu le fracas là évidemment ça
venait de là haut un évier le temps de
descendre et de la toiture et autres
miracles sur les champs elysées les
grande roue installée pour les
festivités de l'an 2000 ont tenu bon
il n'y a que de légers des gardes et les
gens qui sont tombés ça des barrières
dans tous les sens vous pouvez rien
faire tant il fallait attendre que tout
se calme pour pouvoir faire quelque
chose ici par contre il n'ya plus qu'à
constater le désastre de ces cirques qui
devait ouvrir dans deux jours il ne
reste que quelques armature métallique
maigre consolation pour les forains une
telle tempête était pratiquement
imprévisibles sur paris les spécialistes
l'appelle déjà la tempête du siècle dans
l'île de france les dégâts sont très
importants notamment dans l'oise val
d'oise et des yvelines
mais c'est à versailles que la tempête
semble avoir fait le plus de ravages
dans le parc du château
plus de 4000 arbres ont été déracinés la
toiture a été endommagée
florent muller et marie richard le parc
du roi-soleil saccagé par les vents en
deux heures près de 4000 arbres
centenaires se sont inclinés devant les
bourrasques de 120 kilomètres heure
aujourd'hui vers ça y ressemble un
château de cartes certaines fenêtres ont
volé en éclats et les échafaudages
menace de s'écrouler devant ce désastre
les déesses de pierre en sont réduites à
jouer les charpentiers de fortune selon
un premier état des lieux la tempête a
été plus violente encore que celle de
1990 qui avait déjà coûté des millions
au château il cela pourrait s'aggraver
quand il ya des trous
partout dans les toitures si la pluie
arrive avec ont eu le temps de vaches et
de fermer on aura des dégâts dressage
c'est un peu une course contre la mort
toutefois qu'actuellement tout le
personnel est en train d'essayer de
boucher de colmater très vite jusqu'à
nouvel ordre le château est fermée au
public car la forêt est particulièrement
dangereuse à versailles
un homme a été tué par la chute d'un
arbre et de nombreuses routes ont été
éventrés mais les arbres ne sont pas
seuls en cause rue des chantiers on a
frôlé la catastrophe
une grue d'une trentaine de mètres s'est
écrasé sur un bâtiment en construction
les vents l'ont arraché de sa base et
celle ci est venu s'échouer dans le
jardin de la résidence voisine
tout s'est joué à quelques millimètres
pour les propriétaires de l'appartement
du dernier étage un peu secoué c'était
sais pas je pense j'ai jamais entendu
une bombe mais pour moi c'était un peu
comme une bombe
comment c'était une énorme bombe qui
tombe à côté de notre immeuble parce que
finalement nous on était encore vivant
oui mais les morceaux de grue à côté oui
les trois sociétés entre les deux
c'était entre les délais pour moi je me
suis rendu compte que je devais être
miraculé
toute la matinée françoise et son mari
ont tenté de joindre un couvreur
en vain il faudra se faire au goutte à
goutte du plafond fendue et pour la
fenêtre on se contentera quelques jours
d'un carton personnes dans l'immeuble ne
comprend pourquoi cette grille n'a pas
été démontés malgré l'avis de tempête
d'autant qu'à quelques mètres d'autres
menacent toujours tout tombait sourire
ce soir moi je me sens pas là avec mes
deux enfants je me sentais victoire vous
allez faire c'est pas facile de dormir
et qu'on aura presque pas trop loin des
crues non je trouve ça j'ai peur à la
gare de meudon là encore on est passé à
quelques mètres du drame
un arbre a transpercé la voix une pincée
de secondes avant le passage du train et
de ses voyageurs
mais bien souvent le choc a été
inévitable
en ce lendemain de fête beaucoup se sont
réveillés avec une triste surprise et ce
n'est pas forcément au père noël qu'il
faut en vouloir
ce soir un million et demi de foyers
sont toujours privés d'électricité selon
edf qui demande de ne pas toucher aux
lignes électriques tombés au sol
fait exceptionnel le plan orsec a été
déclenché dans quatre départements les
vosges la marne la haute-marne et la
meurthe et moselle
reportage dans l'est de la france avec
nos correspondants à strasbourg jérôme
soûlard et patrice thomas cher des
rafales à 160 kilomètres/heure avec une
telle force les toitures se soulève
comme des feuilles les antennes bastille
et les routes deviennent vite
impraticable dans cette tornade
deux personnes vont trouver la mort lui
noyer l'autre écrasé par la chute d'un
arbre sur sa voiture au nord de
strasbourg
la forêt de brumath et en partie dévasté
les axes de circulation sont presque
totalement bloqués c'est d'ailleurs le
premier travail des pompiers
établir la sécurité sur les principaux
axes de communication ce qui fait en
priorité chez nous c'était donc dégager
les chaussées en nous montrant des
permanents et puis éviter qu'il
yad'autres donc que tu d'arbres sur
éventuellement des voitures qui passent
à quelques kilomètres de là
ce sont des pylônes et ds que le vent a
brisé tel de simples château de cartes
les lignes à haute tension sont tombés
sur l'autoroute de paris des centaines
d'automobilistes étaient encore bloqués
en fin d'après midi
on a vu les arbres tombés sur les voies
dures alors on s'est dit on va rentrer
ça fait plus de deux heures de trois
heures bloqués ici trois heures
c'est pas fini je pense pas à pas l'air
de bouger beaucoup plus de routes et
plus de train non plus depuis ce matin
l'ensemble du réseau sncf est
complètement paralysée pour les arrivées
tout est bloqué aucun train depuis 9h ce
matin ne rentre il ne peut quitter la
gare de strasbourg
conséquence les voyageurs bloqués
devront être relogées dans des wagons
couchettes car les prévisions météo
restent pessimistes
nous restons très vigilants pour la
soirée car mais la météo nous annonce
une reprise du vent autour de 100
kilomètres heure pour la fin de soirée
en alsace les dégâts de cette champêtre
est ce soir très important cent vingt
mille foyers sont d'ailleurs toujours
privés d'électricité et en bretagne une
catastrophe s'ajoute à une autre puisque
nos commence à monter dans plusieurs
villes trois personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans un accident de la route entre
saint brieuc et rennes
le point avec olivier sio et christian
pollet après la marée noire la tempête
partout en bretagne les mêmes images
d'arbres abattus et de toitures
arrachées aux routes coupées sur la voie
express entre saint brieuc et rennes
trois personnes ont trouvé la mort après
la chute d'un arbre
cinq voitures sont venues s'y encastrer
dans les côtes d'armor à bégard c'est
une maison de retraite qui a été très
sérieusement endommagé une partie du
toit s'est envolé avant de s'écraser 100
mètres plus loin
mais heureusement sans faire de victime
pendant tout
depuis ce matin on transfère et les lie
dans d'autres chambres et suis donc là
on est parti pour trois semaines un mois
je ne sais pas comment dans la même
commune c'est la foudre qui a frappé une
maison les occupants ont pu s'échapper à
temps avant qu'elle ne brûle
complètement dans les côtes d'armor le
département le plus touché les pompiers
ont été débordés toute la journée
les armes sont
tombés sur les lignes et donc ça a coupé
l'ensemble de nos appels 18 de leur
réception 18 sont prises on fait face
je pense que tout s'est bien passé mais
c'est vrai que le rythme est affolant
rythme affolant aussi pour edf dans
toute la bretagne plus de deux cent
mille foyers ont été privés
d'électricité
pour près de 20 mille d'entre eux le
courant ne sera rétablie que demain ce
soir le gouvernement a envoyé à rennes
le secrétaire d'état à l'outre-mer
prendre la mesure de la situation
trois mille hommes pourraient être
déployés au total sur les fronts de la
tempête et sur celui de la marée noire
dès que ce sera possible certaines
équipes qui devaient se rendre dans le
grand ouest ont été bloqués à cause de
la tempête vous pouvez plus dégarnir
certains départements nous devons faire
face sur beaucoup de fronts à la fois la
tempête et la pollution maritime est un
nouveau coup de vent est prévue pour 7
nuits pour l'année suivante ce qui ne
devrait pas arranger la situation
les inondations risquent maintenant
d'ajouter une nouvelle calamité à la
série noire que traverse la bretagne
dans la marne le moulin de valmy symbole
des luttes révolutionnaires n'a pas
résisté à la tempête dans tout le pays
en fait on ne compte plus les dégâts qui
sont extrêmement spectaculaires alors
qu'un nouvel avis de tempête est
annoncée pour ce soir la sécurité civile
recommande surtout de ne pas sortir
voyez ces images commentées par hervé
brusini quatre morts le calvados
dénombre aujourd'hui quatre victimes
jour même de noël ce fut une ferme qui
s'écoulait sous le coup d'une
mini-tornade une femme de 51 ans et un
homme de 39 décédé sous les décombres
une fillette de 4 ans est grièvement
blessé aujourd'hui un homme a glissé du
toit qu'ils tentaient de réparer une
femme a été tuée sous sa maison arrachés
par la tempête routes secondaires
bloqués cent dix mille foyers privés
d'électricité
et ce soir une partie du département qui
est sous les eaux
160 km/heure à colmar et dans le centre
de l'alsace autant dire que la région a
été soumise à rude épreuve deux blessés
graves sous le clocher de cette église
par miracle aucune victime sous celui
mais deux femmes ont trouvé la mort une
branche qui vient frapper une passante
et la noyade pour une autre surprise par
la montée des eaux
ici les rafales de vent se sont
engouffrés dans la barre d'immeuble cité
des pétrels alors brutalement vécu
l'angoissé d'une véritable tempête
cheminée ce bâtiment juste au-dessus
bâton besson voulait des volets des
vitres cassées et puis g20 on a essayé
de mettre la table au travers la fenêtre
pour tenir les fenêtres qui bouge
énormément
par précaution on a évacué les 150
personnes qui vivent là la bâtisse
montrait ses premières fissures et du
pouce de vitry-le-françois ont retrouvé
dans le gymnase du vieux-port des 350
passagers du train budapest paris qui
venait d'être stoppée à reims la
violence du vent a dévasté tout ce qui
ne pouvait résister aux 150 km heure de
cette même tornade submergé les pompiers
ont reçu plus de 3000 à peine les 160
hommes sur place ne suffisait pas à la
préfecture une cellule de crise tente de
gérer la situation plus d'électricité
voies de communications coupées et
surtout un nouveau coup de vent qui
s'annonce pour ce soir
le trafic sncf est toujours très
perturbé en france avec notamment des
milliers de personnes bloquées dans les
gares en notamment dans la région rhône
alpes plusieurs trains ont été arrêtés
dans la région de chambéry en raison des
intempéries
reportage de virginie fichés et thierry
monnier trois quarts d'heure et comme
prévu ce groupe regagnera paris ce soir
mais en autocar moins chanceux quelques
1500 voyageurs échoué en gare de
chambéry et qui au fil de la journée
sont allés d'espoir en désillusions bas
ce matin j'ai pris le train pour aller à
paris on a fait demi tour et là
j'attends j'attends que le nouvel avis
changent pour remonter sur paris
ok je sais pas quand est-ce que ça va au
total aujourd'hui une quarantaine de
trains ont été perturbé sur l'ensemble
des départements alpes en laissant près
de 12000 usagers en vacances forcées
avec demain matin enfin voilà clan pipe
ces conditions météo prendre avec le
sourire on n'a pas le choix
un contretemps que tous n'accepte pas
avec le même sourire justement la seule
chose qu'on entend c'est maintenant il
faut prendre notre mal en patience
donc merci la sncf c'est possible c'est
excellent et on dirait oui parce qu'on
est là depuis 10 heures ce matin qu'on a
pris 1 8 heures à bourg saint maurice et
qu'on nous a rien dit et qu'on aurait dû
au moins que nous informer et la tente
ne fait que commencer
en fin d'après midi le trafic vers paris
n'était toujours pas rétablie les
voyageurs égarés songer à s'organiser
c'est ce qu'il ya dessous de nous la
sorte
donc ce sont donc nous héberger sa
cellule de crise ou et henry avec le
plan d'hébergement d'urgence est prévue
pour plus de 20000 personnes donc nous
avons nous avons de la marge ce que nous
essayons de faire c'est de faire que
l'ensemble des personnes qui vont devoir
que c'est un savoir le reste dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
finalement dans la soirée huit tgv
devaient tout de même quitté la région
pour rejoindre la capitale à la sncf
comme sur les quais on espère désormais
en retour à la normale dès 6 heures
demain matin et ce soit en effet un tgv
a pu quitter bourg saint maurice en
savoie pour paris trois autres trains
sont annoncés et emprunteront un
itinéraire de délestage
reste que la plupart des liaisons tgv
entre paris et la province sont annulés
jusqu'à demain le trafic aérien a été
lui aussi fortement perturbé d'une
manière générale les responsables de la
sécurité civile recommande à chacun de
renoncer à circuler que ce soit par air
par train ou en voiture est à des lieues
avec thiriez il ne partira pas il
restera à quai la cause la tempête
voyageurs dépités tgv immobilisé le
trafic ferroviaire a connu un dimanche
exceptionnel
aucun train au départ et à l'arrivée sur
paris excepté paris lille paris rennes
et paris nantes
aucun trafic en lorraine très grosses
perturbations à lyon et jusqu'à 19
heures en haute tarentaise
aucun tgv au départ de marseille et ce
jusqu'à lundi matin
mais le trafic devrait redevenir normale
dès demain matin excepté le sud-est un
numéro pour se renseigner
08 36 67 68 69 trafic de banlieue prévue
demain gare saint-lazare très perturbé 1
train sur 3 sur la ligne b et d du rer
ainsi que paris est et paris nord en ce
qui concerne les avions le trafic a été
rétabli à la mi-journée les aéroports de
roissy-charles-de-gaulle orly bâle
mulhouse et strasbourg ont été fermés de
longues heures et d'ailleurs bâle
mulhouse et strasbourg pourrait bien
refermer à orly huit avions de
différentes compagnies ont été
légèrement endommagés ainsi que
plusieurs structures et systèmes
informatiques secondaire selon eux des
huit cent mille à un million et demi de
personnes serait ce soir encore privés
d'électricité régions les plus touchées
la bretagne la vendée lille
france les vosges et le jura edf
recommande de ne jamais touché une ligne
électrique tombée à terre au dessus d'un
axe la rochelle colmar tout le réseau
routier a été touchée on ne compte plus
les arbres et les panneaux arrachés
ainsi que les routes à circulation
alternée l'autoroute a13 est coupée à
orgeval ainsi que la 14e vers paris
province l'a86 est coupée à maisons
alfort et l'on prévoit pour la soirée de
gros embouteillages en direction de
paris à toulouse météo france estime que
c'est la tempête la plus grave que la
france ait connu depuis une cinquantaine
d'années un phénomène météorologique
dont l'ampleur était difficilement
prévisibles reportage de dorothée
cochard et david bres fujitsu vpp 700 un
nom bien barbare pour une machine fort
élaboré à l'abri isolé dans les sous
sols de météo france toulouse ce
superordinateur traite plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'opérations par
seconde
il réceptionne des données observées
dans le monde entier et l'abordé
prévisions qui apparaissent quasi
instantanément sur les ordinateurs des
météorologues
un outil précieux efficace mais jamais
suffisant qui dit prévisions dit
incertitude 1,6 si on savait ce qui se
passera demain offre de la prévision au
frais du pronostic donc la difficulté
c'est de prendre en compte ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ce que nos modèles
mathématiques prévoit pour demain
après-demain et de l'utiliser pour ça
pour essayer de coller au plus juste à
ce qui se passera réellement et les
météorologues avaient bien prévu cette
tempête d'une rare violence venus
d'outre-atlantique
en revanche ce qui était quasi
impossible à prévoir avec précision ce
sont les mini tourbillon si dévastateur
qui se sont formés à l'intérieur même de
cette dépression je vais donner un
exemple simple prenez un prenez une
tasse de café le matin et donner un
petit coup de cuillère à l'intérieur
vous allez voir apparaître un certain
nombre de tourbillon et certains de ces
tourbillons son sens d'une échelle
microscopique et se forme 100 ans sans
qu'on ne sache et pourquoi
seule certitude ce soir une autre
dépression gagne en ce moment même le
nord du pays
ces rafale devrait encore dépasser les
100 km heure isabelle c'est une tempête
exceptionnelle qui a traversé le nord de
la france et qui a frappé paris ce matin
au lever du jour
c'est vrai que sur ces régions météo
france n'avait jamais vu ça dans la
mesure où généralement ce type des
phénomènes circule un peu plus au nord
avec temps donc plus souvent
l'angleterre que la france mais ce matin
c'est vraiment une dépression
exceptionnelle qui s'est organisée un
peu comme une tornade et qu'elle
circulait très rapidement puisque elle a
traversé l'atlantique en 24 heures à 4
heures elle était déjà sur la bretagne
elle aborder la bretagne est à 10 heures
elle quittait déjà le pays à 14 ans elle
est sûre la pologne
il lui a suffi que de six heures pour
ravager complètement le nord du pays
avec des vents d'une extrême violence et
isabelle ce soir météo france incite
chacun à la plus grande prudence parce
que ce n'est pas tout à fait terminée
tout à fait prudent ce soir et cette
nuit dans la mesure où un autre
phénomène est en train de balayer le
pays en suivant la même trajectoire
ça aussi c'est rare ce phénomène est
accompagné de vents un peu moins violent
c'est vrai mais quand même 120
kilomètres à l'heure les rafales étant
associé à des nuages d'orage donc le
danger est réel
et puis il faut également savoir que un
autre coup de vent est prévu dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi prochain sur les
côtes de l'aquitaine
donc un seul conseil si vous en avez la
possibilité restez chez vous et nous
vous retrouvons isabelle à la fin de ce
journal évidemment les pays voisins ont
également été durement touchée en suisse
la tempête a fait au moins 11 morts pour
la plupart écrasés par des chutes
d'arbres une télécabine c'est aussi
décroché dans la station de ski de crans
montana en allemagne on compte déjà 12
morts et de très nombreux blessés
et puis en grande bretagne ce sont cinq
personnes qui ont acquis sont décédées
selon un dernier bilan
déjà hier les autorités britanniques
avaient demandé l'évacuation de
plusieurs milliers de personnes habitant
le long des côtes
les conditions météorologiques
catastrophiques n'ont évidemment pas
arrangé les choses sur les fronts de la
marée noire
toute la côte de loire-atlantique entre
la baule au sud et la turballe au nord a
été touchée cette nuit par des nappes de
fioul lourd
les vents très violents et la forte
houle ont considérablement gêné le
travail des secouristes
on estime aujourd'hui que près de 10
mille oiseaux ont déjà été victimes de
la marée noire
reportage au croisic de joël bruandet et
blaise grenier
c'est un peu comme si la marée avait du
mal à monter trop de pétrole ce matin du
croisic à la baule
les habitants du littoral ne
reconnaissent pas leurs plages on
attendait d'ici quelques nappes dispersé
c'est une vraie marée noire qui est
arrivé la nuit dernière et avec elle la
colère
so passé grand leur bateau et faire
trois pas plus non sans mettre plus
d'une fois durant pour plus ce matin au
croisic
les gens sont encore hébété et tarde un
peu à se mobiliser
du côté des autorités locales on est
plutôt dépassé instant il ya une réunion
qui est en crise en mairie donc tous ces
vins bassement mairie sont en train
d'essayer de gérer le problème et nous
les verrons certainement pas là cet
après midi pourtant les bénévoles sont
arrivés en masse armés de pelles et de
râteaux objectif ramasser le maximum de
pétrole avant que la mer ne remonte avec
eux sur le terrain la sécurité civile
les pompiers mais aussi une foule
considérable de badauds les gens elle
sera 30 se promener pour voir les côtes
comment c'est dégueulasse il ferait pas
mal de prendre un petit sauf une petite
pelle pour de donna coumakoye ce que
l'inter décor est content d'avoir une
belle cote comme on a on vient pêcher
d'où il ya tout ce qu'il faut là ça va
être un désastre au présent et se
rendent bien compte de ce havre les
autorités où il est impossible à l'heure
actuelle de savoir où la tempête
emmènera le reste du pétrole qui flotte
encore large
mais une chose est sûre des milliers de
tonnes de fuel menaçait encore les côtes
ce soir le vent continue à souffler très
fort sur la côte sauvage et des nappes
comme celles-ci continuaient à s'échouer
sur le littoral déjà souillées il a
fallu toute une journée aux habitants de
la région pour réaliser ce qui vient de
leur arriver
il leur faudra probablement des mois
pour tout nettoyer à belle isle la marée
noire a atteint hier la côte sauvage et
il a fallu redéployer les dispositifs de
secours et volontaires étaient nombreux
ce matin pour aider à nettoyer les côtes
souillées reportage d'anne consignes et
et valérie lucas est une petite crique
ici le dax est un groupe de jeunes de
bale il nous dit a conduit en véhicule
tout terrain
il en avait assez d'entendre parler de
pollution en tatouant galette
il voulait nous montrer que dans cette
scic le fioul a tout recouvert
et malgré le temps particulièrement
mauvais cet après midi ils se sont mis
au travail en plus ensemble noir mois
dans l'eau surya dh pas comme un tanga
dans la flotte nouveau c'est déjà ça en
moins y'a rien n'avait plus passé pareil
à part que j'avais une grosse la petite
balade est grand certaines plages sont
plus accessibles que celle là et
permettent l'intervention des machines
les quarante hommes de la sécurité
civile présents sur l'île se sont
déployés cet après midi sur deux sites
aux côtés des bénévoles
deux à trois cents personnes au total
mais déjà les clips la bague premier
bond quand même les plages sont réputées
plus facile à défaut muet mais celle-ci
caillouteuses on a gratté un peu près
150 cm mais sur une longueur à peu près
de 50 60 mètres mon ami quand même 4 5
euros pour le faire donc c'est assez
assez pénible de nombreux habitants de
l'île ont proposé un hébergement aux
continentaux qui viendrait les aider
mais la cellule de crise n'est pas
favorable à cette solution
elle estime ne pas être en mesure de
coordonner l'action de bénévoles qui
connaissent mal la côte de l'île et ses
falaises dangereuse
anne bonsoir vous êtes en direct de ben
ali est-ce que les moyens de lutte
contre la pollution sont à la hauteur
des besoins élevés en réalité donc je
voulais dit un certain nombre de
bénévoles du continent proposer leurs
services un certain nombre d'habitants
de l'île proposé de les héberger le
président du district qui regroupe les
quatre communes de belle île ne souhaite
pas les voir arriver
pour les raisons de sécurité que nous
avons mais aussi parce qu'ils n'ont pas
suffisamment de matériel pour équiper
d'ores et déjà les deux à trois cents
volontaires présents sur l'île c'est le
problème de belle île il n'y avait pas
de matériel pré positionnés sur l'île
aucun bateau n'a pu en apporter
aujourd'hui dans le port qui se trouve
en contrebas et en raison des conditions
météo et demain il dans des bateaux
doivent apporter du matériel
mais ce sera insuffisant belle il a
besoin de seaux de pelles de cube voire
de ben
en ce qui concerne les dégâts il est
d'ores et déjà il est beaucoup trop tôt
pour savoir ce que la marée haute
ramènera demain sur les plages en termes
d'hydrocarbures mais en revanche on peut
déjà dire que pour les oiseaux le bilan
est assez lourd puisque rien que sur
belle île
plus de 2000 volatiles ont été récupérés
mort ou gaz ou thé et dominique voynet
qui était hier sur france 2 faisait part
de la difficulté à évaluer l'ampleur de
la pollution
elle s'est rendue dans la matinée à
noirmoutier des traces de fioul ont été
retrouvés dans l'estuaire de la loire ce
matin albon nicosie et olivier jour n'ya
on suivi tout au long de cette journée
la ministre de l'environnement de dans
les jours qui viennent par les jours
précédents ton et le lombard
mais dominique voynet ne s'attendait pas
à être reçus ici avec des fleurs dans la
région du croisic la marée noire est
bien visible et c'est cela l'urgence des
bénévoles des agents municipaux affronte
le mazout il y adeux l'écoeurement et de
la colère
vingt ans qu'on a eu la moco on pense
qu'on est capable de faire quelque chose
depuis pour s'aperçoit que vous de bâton
n'y a strictement rien ne ferait on
arrive au même problème
hier la vie qui se répand très important
regardez la gravité quand même
aujourd'hui elle reconnaît un petit peu
que c'est grave ce sont deux espèces qui
sont également ici devant les hyènes de
dizaines d'oiseaux on croit en effet
faire un bond en arrière alors dominique
voynet explique avant tout qu'elle ne
mésestime pas les ravages de la
pollution et qu'il faut durcir la
réglementation mais dans un cadre
international
j'avoue que je suis ébranlé moi quand
j'entends dire qu'un bureau d'experts
italiens reconnu comme un des bons
bureau d'experts aurait réalisé une
expertise de l'erika ça pose problème
non seulement sur hull le dispositif
expertise mais aussi sur la nature de ce
qui a expertisé loin qu'on donne pour
vérifier en vendée elle a présidé ce
matin une cellule de crise avec philippe
de villiers le président du conseil
général
l'urgence a dépassé un moment les
clivages politiques
mi février un sommet à paris rassemblera
acteurs locaux et gouvernement pour tiré
à froid des conclusions la marée noire
ce soir c'est ont donc d'une zone allant
de la pointe du finistère jusqu'à saint
gilles croix de vie il est très
difficile d'identifier l'origine réelle
du mazout a mené sur les plages par une
mer démontée
état des lieux avec christelle bertron
erika le pétrolier maltais a sombré le
12 décembre avec lui trente mille tonnes
de fioul lourd avec vents et marées les
premières galettes d'hydrocarbure ont
touché les côtes de belle-ile le 24
décembre quatorze jours après le
naufrage la pollution restent difficiles
à localiser en raison de la forte houle
provoquée par la tempête
sur cette carte les zones noires
représentent les plaques d'hydrocarbures
signalées elles s'étendent du sud de la
bretagne à la loire atlantique les
pointillés indique les zones
susceptibles d'être touchées dans les
jours à venir
dans le sud-finistère 110 km de côtes
sont déjà souillées par le fioul cet
après midi l'île de noirmoutier est
polluée à son tour
selon météo france la nappe devrait
continuer sa course vers le sud et
atteindre lundi saint gilles croix de
vie
en côte d'ivoire mais la nuit a été
calme à abidjan après la deuxième nuit
de couvre feu le général robert gueï est
en passe de réussir son coup de force
les commandants militaires des
différentes armes infanterie
parachutistes marine gendarmerie se sont
ralliés à lui ainsi que le numéro deux
du parti du président bédié qui cet
après midi à quitter abidjan avec sa
famille pour se réfugier à lomé au togo
le général robert gueï a par ailleurs
refusé tout renforcement du dispositif
militaire français dans son pays
reportage du correspondant permanent
eric monier et roger motte
l'ambassadeur de france pour regagner sa
résidence ses négociations avec le
nouveau pouvoir entamer il ya 48 heures
ont enfin abouti
henri konan bédié le président déchu
réfugié dans ce camp des forces
françaises basées en côte d'ivoire vient
de quitter le pays avec sa famille
épilogue d'une prise de pouvoir en
douceur des militaires ivoiriens dès ce
matin abidjan donnait une image de
dimanche à peu près normal la
circulation avait repris des bus si
lionel avis les badauds se pressaient
devant les magasins pillés 36 heures
plus tôt des pillages spectaculaires
mais limité à quelques rues commerçantes
de la capitale économique ivoirienne
ici ce qu'il reste d'une boutique
d'électroménager appartenant pas un
france
une catastrophe j'sais pas comment faire
franchement c'est c'est dur c'est dur
enfin bon c'est la vie il va falloir
faire le nécessaire pour recommencer
dans la rue la foule compatis et
argumente nous de pleura nous le
regrettons ce qui s'est passé wayne
simmonds et vous pensez que ça y est
c'est fini mais temps s'annonce est
finie on mettait la situation c'est fini
l'or qui viennent se mettre en confiance
le gouvernement s'était déjà responsable
un nouveau gouvernement que le général
kheir
le nouveau chef de l'état annonce pour
bientôt un général ancien chef d'état
major et hamidou foot boigny dont le
charisme dépasse largement le cadre de
l'armée et qui veut aller vite
dès hier ralliement télévisées les plus
hautes personnalités de l'ère bédié qui
décide
cet après midi remise en route de
l'administration qui devrait fonctionner
normalement demain et pour faire bonne
figure
la population a pu se rendre aujourd'hui
au camp militaire d'akouédo pour
réclamer la restitution de ces véhicules
empruntent et quelques jours par les
militaires pour cause de coup d'état
il aura fallu moins de 48 heures pour
qu'un mouvement d'humeur de jeunes
soldats ne tourne en prise de pouvoir en
surfant sur une vague de mécontentement
général que ni l'ancien président ni son
allié la france l'avait prise au sérieux
cette nuit l'équipe de discovery a
relâché le télescope hubble dans
l'espace c'est le français jean françois
clervoy qui était aux commandes pour
cette opération qualifiée de succès
total par les ingénieurs de la nasa
commentaire de patrice pollet
sur fond de terre le télescope hubble
s'éloigne de la navette
l'image est magnifique et clôturent
cette mission une mission qui est donc
un vrai succès mais qui avait
difficilement comment ces neuf reports
de lancement de moi ils sont sept à bord
dont le français jean françois clervoy
il est responsable de la capture de
beule et du déplacement des astronautes
au bout du bras robotique et ils vont se
mettre au travail
trois sorties difficiles épuisante de
huit heures chacune
mais le programme est respecté les
gyroscopes l'ordinateur les censeurs
tout est changé
le télescope est remise à neuf
clervoy l'équipage la nasa les
astrophysiciens tout ce soit sont ravis
et puis cet après midi nous avons pu
joindre l'espace est interrogé en direct
de la navette discovery jean françois
clervoy l'astronaute français et qui
j'ai demandé si c'était plus
impressionnant d'effectuer la réparation
en réel qu'à l'entraînement en fait à
l'entraînement parce que à travers les
fenêtres alors qu'entre deux caméras la
perception du relief avec nos propres
jeux en regardant par la fenêtre
donc quel souvenir le plus fort
apportez-vous de 7,7 équipé avec avec
l'équipe autour de vous la première des
autres nos enfants millions et de
revenir avec la mission accomplie sans
avoir eu de problème majeur de pancakes
sur un complice pour la millions nous
avons rendu à l'étape en parfaite santé
capable recommencer
et donc de nous apporter de nouvelles
réponses dans les années qui viennent
alors si demain à la fin de ce beau
voyage site avec un peu de nostalgie que
vous allez revenir sur terre on ne se
lasse pas de regarder la terre merci
beaucoup monsieur je vous dis au revoir
je ne sais pas si vous voyez et encore
bravo comme battu la chine avait barré
rapine yeux mais a tous voila et vous
l'aurez remarqué le son est
désynchronisé c'est un décalage normal
compte tenu de la vitesse de déplacement
de la navette 27 mille kilomètres heure
pour cette fin d'année l'opéra bastille
présente la belle au bois dormant ballet
de tchaïkovski que rudolph noureev vais
régler pour l'opéra de paris
les décors et les costumes sont
éblouissants les danseurs au mieux de
leur forme
un spectacle enchanteur visible jusqu'au
21 janvier george v go et jean louis
merlin ont aussi été séduit
oh
c'est la fête au château une enfant
vient de naître belle comme le jour
on l'appelle aurore c'est l'occasion de
grandes réjouissances à la cour toutes
les bonnes fées viennent danser et se
pencher sur son berceau
mais aussi hélas la fée carabosse ne me
dites pas que vous connaissez l'histoire
tchaïkovski a composé d'après le conte
de charles perrault un somptueux ballet
romantique à souhait le préféré de
rudolf noureev qui en a dirigé la
chorégraphie à l'opéra de paris
aurélie dupont la plus jeune des étoiles
de l'opéra dans ce rôle de la belle
euros pour la première fois quand la
belle au bois dormant donc la princesse
aurore s'endort elle s'endort pas juste
ça chez pas une sieste comme on a
l'impression que dans les contes de fées
au contraire elle se repose pour un look
et une maturité pour qu'elles deuxième
femme
manuel legris danse le rêve d'amour de
désir et avec la grâce et le talent qui
conviennent au prince charmant
au réveil aurore se lance dans des
pirouettes éblouissant
ans
fin dans le très beau décor des yeux
offrit germinaux le mariage est célébré
et le croirez-vous le prince et la belle
aurore pur heureux et eurent beaucoup de
petits danseurs
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous en
rappelle le principal titre la plus
grave tempête qui est connue paris
depuis 50 ans a balayé toute la moitié
nord de la france avec des vents très
violents provoquant la mort d'au moins
27 personnes
les transports routier aérien ou
ferroviaire sont encore gravement
perturbé un million et demi de foyers
sont toujours privés d'électricité dans
un instant isabelle martinez vous
donnera les dernières informations sur
le nouvel avis de tempête lancée par
météo france
à 20h55 l'incontournable grande
vadrouille avec bourvil et louis de
funès et digdash bien sûr à 01 25
journal de la nuit de florence duprat de
master 50 dans les 4 vérités
roland castro architectes et urbanistes
à 13h vous retrouverez carole gaessler
et rachid arhab matters coutrillons
excellent trait à tous bon soir
oh